mehr lassen und dann läuft der
bildfläche weg alter das pack ich
nachher so das musst du dir auf jeden
fall auf dem ganz cooney und das ist
ganz oben ernährungskette und dann hast
du irgendwie ein stack von allen sachen
bekommen und diamanten paar 11 stück
glaube ich meine sachen wieder
und auch wenn sachen und mehr
freunde irgendwann lade ich euch auf ein
bierchen ein oder sollten angebot
nämlich an
apropos seite auf der gamescom in köln
also ziemlich und lena ja ich weiß nicht
ob ich da hinkommen soll ich mich mich
reizt
diesmal geht es jetzt hast mich gesehen
und dann hat sich irgendwann
bewahrheitet dass du da drin war kann
ich war das gar nicht naja mein
vorgänger das war ein doppelgänger war
das außerdem gibt es kaum kraft dann
real life gar nicht ist so ich bin ein
lebendes phänomen
ich wollte mir meine kiste gucken so in
der art locker ich hab jetzt in dem ich
anders verteilen nicht aufgenommen habe
ungefähr 26 eisen blöcke in meiner kiste
einfach will es mit einblicken machen zu
waisen machen und anderen meisten haben
man braucht viel eisen aber ich muss
reise machen und ameisen haben zum
beispiel für solarpanels brauchst du ja
er habe es klappt es lohnt sich schon
dass meine automatische solar panel
produktion baut fahrrad warum ich in
diesem da wo ich gerade bin ich du hast
du die post für solarpanels pro solar
panel 1 23
denn für batterien gar nichts 4 567 8000
waren pro solar panel unter brauchs 512
oder für ein high voltage größe schon
meine solar panels mein mfs uhr lädt
sich nicht mal auf obwohl der 411 au und
1 mv solarpanel daran hat dass verliebt
sich nicht mal auf weil damals noch
alles gut ich ja wenn es nicht
unglaublich wirklich alles aber geht ja
noch weiter am hallo nach meint ihr
geratet ihr mir dass ich auf in zukunft
technisch gesehen umsteigen soll auf
gegen andere energie sollte
oder soll ich bei low voltage oder es
bleiben immer mehr davon bauen aber
eigentlich sind schon sinn weil ich
steigt jetzt um von atomkraft auf 11 auf
solarenergie gut nur so gegen atomkraft
leute unsere ganze generationen haben
merkel sagt energiewende 80 opel merkel
sagt auch internet lasse für mich
neuland aber das macht für mich ich
liebe dich ich habe nicht mein name
selber ich habe übrigens noch den
scanner
ach so aber die bildschirme haben
deswegen die chancen stehen schlecht für
dich ja kannst du dich behalten
ich weiß nicht möglich zu machen also
könnt ihr euch ab und muss einfach
endlich machen wenn du auf wenn
irgendein gang bis zum beispiel die
letzte die von einigen turtle graben
also dass am tunnel halt die funktion
und dann drückt einfach wenn du unten
drin bis auf 416 oder sowas dann richtig
und wo der wert halt irgendwie über 80
ist oder so sind halt entweder richtig
richtig viele ärzte oder halt einfach
diamant da kann man halt relativ gut
diamant mitfahren aber klappt nicht so
gut also geht mir besser zurück dass er
irgendwas in einem haus ist gemischt
wieso lukas reimann ist noch nicht
fertig aber wirklich das ist etwas ist
ganz komisch ihr heute dafür dass ich
fliege entweder er will mich töten oder
er irgendwas kaputt gemacht oder ist
einfach den
in unter dieses geld schon gegeben
aufnimmt und auch mitzumachen
man hab ich einfach mal hin geschlossen
ich kann das gar nicht ja den atollen
zauberstab hatte da ich kann das nicht
möglich macht
mehr lasse habe ich nicht unser läuft
der bildfläche weg alter das pack ich
nachvollziehen so das musst du dir auf
jeden fall sind alle kaputt gegangen ich
hab kein glas zu reparieren sorry hast
du das alles kaputt gemacht oder gar
nicht sie haben die geschlossen hier war
da gerade du hast hier bist du gestorben
meine selbst verteidigungsanlage card
geschossen und wieder glas des stifts
also ja ich dachte wohl es einfach
abbauen
außerdem bin ich eh zu schnell für dich
hier ja mit der skater mose bei allem
was hast du eine mission ein ende
gemacht schon hier habe ich den trotzdem
euch danach fleck bei mir im haus
ja ich bin extra hingegangen jetzt
so der tabelle brachte ja kummer prof
ich habe neue spiel kamera soll jetzt
aber du bist so witzig schöne junge
leute das gefängnis oder nicht hier also
parieren
januar wieder kaputt gemacht aber das 1
1 ist von mir ja nein ich muss erstmal
energie auch brauchen denn über die
bachelor muss auf energielevel 0 sein
nachfolger wieder runter bist du witzig
scheiße so plötzlich ist ein jetpack ist
da drin oder wo ist das ich hab das ach
so ja gut und ich bin irgendwie unten
ohne job macht spaß ich hab mir ein
jetpack und zweitens daraus doch hier wo
den hat mehr ahnung aber mein grundstück
als ich also hier auch schade dachte
schon ich bin für immer eingesperrt
keller
du hast ja voll erstattet aber man
bleibt nur reich wenn man auch mal nimmt
oder wie die nordies italo naked tricks
ja ist mir auch aufgefallen
ich war einfach weg beim ihr habt alles
wegen der architektur spielzeug
ausprobieren was das sieht aber schön
das was verbaut ja unseren wasserturm
ist ein bisschen schöner als der von als
der von cap aber es soll unsicher ist er
dem jetzt noch gebaut weil was übrig was
der energie bringen muss also aus wenn
man halt richtig viel macht ja ich aber
bei golem sagen das haus sieht zwar
durch löcher aus aber sieht echt hammer
aus bin ich auch aber auch gesagt mein
haus liegt auf dem webbrowser dagegen
manch anderen hier dein haus ist einfach
lena das ist das ist so typisch ich
gucke von oben drauf ich dachte da
werden loch und auf einmal ist das
wintergarten der modernes aber irgendwie
doch wieder da kommt dann sonne sonne
sondern feature reinen das haus was
einfach so typisch täter sind alles
erschwert uns war dieses fette dem
schild obendrauf zu schlagen
leider gar nichts mit einem autohaus gut
da immer wieder drauf
es ist auch schön glaube diese folge am
wenigsten gemacht bisschen ich kann
immer nur macht eigentlich nichts
richtig ist so langweilig ihm was ein
rolltor emails retter da kriegt das und
steht hier komm ich bin jetzt mal den
tipp und nervt ein bisschen und das ist
eine super idee den erwartet vielleicht
freunde ihr euch ja an sich
er hat übrigens noch mainz
ich bin hier weil ich zu dir unterkommen
wo bisher gibt es zwei löcher
wo mails reichen verlegt wenn ich hier
sehr schwach so groß wie mein
aus
die tassen das ist ein tank die
generatoren sind darunter panzer
einen tag lang von 2008 in den usa ihr
englisch h
hansa kanzler frank ja klar denkt ich
gucke auf sein ding gedacht das sind
eigentlich so heißt das im panzer an
dessen tank
die haben sich gegenseitig kaputt
gemacht weiß dass dadurch entstand und
stupst du ja gut da kann man geld
stellen guckt man diese games genau kate
ist ja alles voll und die kannst du dir
so an die pipes dann schließen und
dadurch werden die items dann versuchen
gepackt und könne nicht überlaufen leute
thema damit die meiste ahnung hiervon
das merkst du jetzt erst ich habe das
bisher alles so von oben gesehen doch zu
bisschen zuckerrohr paar kisten so
ungefähr auf dem level wie ich naja aber
unter der oberfläche schlummert den aus
einfach nur das monster richtiger
kleiner
eine bulldogge so großes maul nichts
dahinter
er steht da jetzt gerade um vor seinen
anlagen weiß einfach nicht was er machen
soll
nein repariert die alle sind alle kaputt
gegangen weiß ich warum die ganze gut
funktioniert sorry ich muss mich noch
mal bei uns spielt bedanken
danke sie greifen mich trotzdem
sie unterscheide nicht zwischen gut und
böse
ich will gehen aber erst gemeint nein
bürger gefängnis hatte ich ja selbst
so kann ich nicht die ganze zeit ja ich
bin noch hier ist bacchus alter ich habe
angst
wisst ihr werk hat doppel hat ja ich
möchte von jemandem klar ich glaube
niemand hatte als ich haue kartoffeln
gesucht potato gang machen wollte
es ist also quasi ein porträt kann nur
halte verkleidet also es gibt ja
verschiedene porto ganz und ich hatte
halt noch offen welche ich mache und es
wäre wohl potato wir machen ja ja aber
ich hab's ja nicht deswegen habe ich
jetzt eine ganz normale pipa die porsche
kann ich habe vier spitzhacke nur weil
ich dafür gegeben habe hier habe ich von
ihm la la la
als durch nhl ihr könnt ihr auch nicht
sagen
die schief nicht heller
na das g8 ist noch zu schwer war jetzt
ein bisschen hart luca dennoch kleben da
muss man mal gucken wo es ist auch kein
leben mit echt mal was hier so
organisieren in meinem leben
die schießen gar nicht mehr die sparkurs
sandy bridge beleidigen willst du
schießen denn der deutsche bund ich als
schpakow mittel beleidigt ja aber auf
den ausbildern nur da kommt ja dann
sollen sie das machen oder weniger auch
für mich da noch mitmachen jeder den ich
bin ich natürlich sehr satten dankbar
für eine bereitschaft